he wants to make the world a little
better every day coach of the u.s.
national team Jurgen Klinsmann
originally from southern Germany he's
now at home in America it's very said
Ubar I've been living here for over 17
years now this to be barking and if you
look at football 30 years ago and where
it is today it's like a little fairy
tale dreams man knows all about fairy
tales in 2006 he was coach of the German
side in the world cup on home soil he
led Germany on a fairytale run the whole
country got behind the team after the
World Cup Klinsmann sought new
challenges his goal now is to take the
u.s. boys to the top of the world game
in the 2014 World Cup they reached the
knockout phase in the country took
notice
they love this meeting sivadas that my
car and the crucial thing was Americans
understanding how emotional soccer can
be caused by saying can be seeing all
those people partying together helps to
connect people that's in Liza's over
door and 2014 so that emotional
breakthrough among the American people
that is a really wicked game hrithik
Irish speeders Klinsmann was nominated
for 2015 German soccer ambassador he
supports a project of the US soccer
foundation which seeks to promote the
sport amongst disadvantaged children he
had their my name during my training
years I always thought things should be
like this or this that's just the way it
is until I understood no people here are
different it's better if I change
because the millions of people here are
not going to change from my benefit
mendini giving me away enough Jurgen
Klinsmann wants to change the world of
football a man with a dream and a true
football ambassador
you